hello i am a sebalg and i'm a graduate
student at the university of minnesota
studying land dynamics for atmospheric
science with an emphasis in manure and
nutrient management
for this poster i will be going over
some preliminary data from research that
is measuring the impacts integrating
cover crops and manure have on soil
health nutrient cycling and agronomic
production
cover crops have been gaining momentum
over the years yet their adoption rates
in the upper midwest are not as robust
as other regions across the united
states
this is especially the case in manure
applied systems
this stems from the short cover crop
growing season due to the prolonged
winters that places in the upper upper
midwest such as in minnesota frequently
have farmers are also hesitant to use
cover crops because limited information
is available on how integrating cover
crops and manure impact crop yield
the objective of this study is to
determine the best management practices
of integrating cover crops and manure
and how that affects corn yields in the
upper midwest
in this study we set up plots at the
university of minnesota west central
research and outreach center located
near morris minnesota
plots were arranged in a randomized
complete block design with split plots
main plots include nutrient source which
was liquid dairy manure applied in the
early fall when soil temperatures were
above 50 degrees fahrenheit or 10
degrees celsius or in late fall when
soil temperatures were below 50 degrees
fahrenheit or 10 degrees celsius through
sweep injection
to minimize soil disturbance
urea is applied in the spring prior to
corn planting for plots not receiving
manure application
we aim to apply the same plant available
night generates across all treatments
the split plot was cover crop seeding
technique slash planting time
winter rye annual rye grass mixtures
were broadcast by hand at the v5 corn
growth stage which you can see in the
picture in the left side of the poster
broadcast by hand at corn physiological
physiological maturity or drilled after
corn harvest
plots receiving urea in the spring with
no cover crops served as a control
overall we first planted cover crops in
the late summer and early fall then
applied manure when the cover crops had
enough time
to grow and establish an active root
system
we thought that by first planting cover
crop prior to manure application the
cover crops may tie up readily available
nutrients into their biomass instead of
being lost to the environment
then once the cover crops were
terminated in the spring they can
release those nutrients to the
succeeding corn crop
we on to preliminary data it is
important to note that the similar
letters above the bars within each graph
indicates a significant effect of our
fixed effects among the treatments
when sampling cover crops in late fall
prior to the first frost event cover
crop biomass which is a y-axis is the
greatest when winter rye annual rye
grass is overseeded near r5 compared to
drilling after harvest
broadcasting at v5 also produce
significantly more biomass than drilling
come spring the story changes a little
bit the highest biomass produced was for
cover crops planted near r5 whereas the
other cover crop treatments were not
statistically different from one another
nutrient sources now have an effect on
cover crop biomass production in both
fall and spring
you may also notice a drop in biomass
production between fall and spring this
is most likely due to annual rye grass
being winter killed unlike the winter
rye which is a very winter hardy cover
crop species
moving on to yield data when looking at
the effects of nutrient source the x
axes have
which is the x axes have on solid yield
the y axis manure either
applied in the early fall or late fall
significantly better than spring applied
durian fertilizer
although nitrogen is applied at similar
rates
manure may be providing other services
other than supply nutrients which may be
positively impacting the soil and
subsequently the corn crops
there was no statistical difference
between the no cover crop and all and
all the cover crop treatments on silage
yield
among the cover crop treatments
broadcasting your v5 had the highest
solid yield
so far we learned that planting cover
crops near plants and essences is a more
optimal time to plant cover crops
overseas at r5 gives cover crops more
time to grow compared to drilling after
harvest while providing enough sunlight
exposure for cover crops to produce more
biomass compared to overseeding before
canopy closure
increased cover crop biomass may reduce
allergies to a certain extent though
ongoing research measuring various soil
health parameters crop nutrient uptake
among other tests are actually are
actively underway
i want to thank the usda nrcs
conservation innovation grants program
the minnesota quorum research and
promotion council and the foundation for
food and agriculture research for the
funds to support this project
i'd like to also thank all personnel at
the west central research and outreach
center and wilson lab for field access
and assistance with fieldwork thank you
for viewing my poster